this little chunk of metal contains
lithium so does the cell phone and this
electric
car the super light metal is a critical
component in batteries and the world's
transition to Green energy it's ignited
a global lithium surge in demand which
is expected to reach nearly 2.5 million
metric tons by 2028 lithium is the wide
gold of the electric age China has
become the world's largest lithium
processor controlling 55% of the market
to fuel its lithium supply chain China
needs to secure raw lithium abroad it's
making risky major investments in
lithium mines in Africa and Latin
America in hopes of controlling onethird
of the world's raw lithium supply as it
competes with countries around the world
to feed a growing demand for lithium
batteries here's why experts say China
is trying to protect and expand its raw
lithium sources and how the US is
struggling to develop its own supply
chain before lithium ends up in all of
these it first has to be processed in
refineries like this one which
transforms lithium compounds into
battery components China specializes as
the world's largest lithium processor
processing about 55% of the world's raw
lithium after processing the mineral it
stays in China or could travel to Japan
or South Korea to be turned into battery
components those batteries are then
shipped around the world including the
US the US processes very little lithium
domestically and it's relying on China's
lithium processing China on the other
hand made significant investments in its
domestic lithium refineries in the
thousands China started doing it because
you need a lot of energy for refining
and you also need the stomach cuz it's a
little bit of a sort of dirty thing to
do China manufactured a lot of these
appliances just got interested in it and
got good in it and then of course there
was also this Push by the Chinese
government to Electrify transportation
and scale up electric vehicles China
currently has the largest market for
electric cars with around 60% of global
electric elect car sales and those cars
need lithium batteries fueling China's
demand for a reliable lithium supply
chain lithium is just incredibly
valuable because it's an essential
component in the technologies that we
need in order to achieve a lot of our
climate goals and to Electrify the world
now in China's case it's just been a
little bit ahead of the curve so for
them in order to maintain their lead and
in order to actually make the things
that they do they need a supply of
lithium but China's supply chain has a
weak link even though it's the world's
largest processor it relies on foreign
countries for much of its raw lithium
including us allies Chinese companies
also mine some lithium domestically and
they're fighting for control Global
lithium prices were about 300% higher in
August than they were at the beginning
of 2021 in China as is the case all over
the world people discovered that lithium
is becoming a very important commodity
demand for the commodity also shut up so
when uh the Local Government auction
rides to explore a mine the bidding W
just started and they they submitted
thousands of bids and the prices went up
one recent auction for exploration
rights at a lithium site in Sichuan
received over 11,000 bids and the
auction for the Jada lithium mine closed
at the equivalent of $580 million 1,300
times higher than its starting price
lithium is an abundant mineral globally
but it's often difficult and expensive
to extract at the moment China actually
doesn't mine a lot of lithium most of
the mining of lithium takes place in
Latin America in
Australia which actually exposes Chinese
companies to a supply chain
vulnerability of getting the raw
material Chinese companies are really
worried that a lot of the countries that
are friendly with the United States
might cut off Chinese companies
abilities to invest um more in these
countries Australia the world's largest
raw lithium supplier blocked the sale of
a mine to a company with a director
holding Chinese citizenship and Canada
has similarly ordered three Chinese
companies to sell their stakes in
Canadian mines instead China is turning
to countries in Africa and Latin America
for riskier raw lithium investments in
the past 2 years Chinese companies have
spent $4.5 billion on stakes in nearly
20 African and Latin American lithium
mines the strategy to go to developing
countries is not without risks because a
lot of these countries have somewhat
unstable political um regimes they're
quite underdeveloped when it comes to
infrastructure and if you want to mine
and do things you need roads you need
power you you need facilities many
nations are also tightening control over
their minds in December Zimbabwe banned
the export of RA lithium instead forcing
companies to process it within the
country country and then there's also
something called resource nationalism so
a lot of these developing countries say
to themselves well you know we have
these resources and selling it as a sort
of raw product actually gets us less
money than if we have a valued added
industry with that so if we for example
process lithium and maybe even one day
um produce our own batteries because
that's actually where you make a lot of
the money and it's also an AB uh an
opportunity to upscale your labor force
but that's obviously easier said than
done and in Latin America Mexico and
Chile are also tightening control while
Chile Bolivia and Argentina are
discussing creating a lithium cartel a
lot of these developing countries come
with their own risks Chinese companies
are also concerned that us Allied
countries could limit their access to
lithium some experts disagree that China
is vulnerable to us allies restricting
their raw lithium and say that China's
investments in Latin America and Africa
are Paving the path for a stronger
supply chain in the future for a lot of
these countries that have lithium China
is actually a very good customer because
it has a steady demand for lithium it
doesn't just buy lithium for lithium's
sake right it buys it because it needs
it for products so you know that they
will be there tomorrow and the day after
tomorrow and um that gives them a lot of
stability in terms of the money that the
revenue that they can get you may not
get the highest price but you get a very
steady price and that can be very
reassuring lithium mining died out in
the US in the 20th century because
companies found cheaper methods to
harvest lithium in South American Salt
Lakes and because there was no mining
refining also left the US now the US
wants to secure its own supply chain to
reduce its Reliance on China but it has
a long way to go propelled by the
inflation reduction act and a growing
demand for green energy sources the US
is also increasing its efforts to tap
into its own lithium deposits and
construct domes btic lithium refineries
tax credits and green energy subsidies
from the inflation reduction act
discount the cost of producing lithium
by 10% enticing companies to make
American lithium Investments Exxon
Mobile plans on entering the lithium
Market by building one of the world's
largest lithium processing facilities in
Arkansas when completed analist
predicted could produce 75,000 to
100,000 metric tons of lithium a year
that would add up to 15% of all finished
lithium product globally but there's a
catch many of these lithium extraction
plants haven't been built yet one
upcoming mine owned by lithium Americas
contains one of the largest known
lithium sources in the US lithium
America's told the Wall Street Journal
that besides one other small operational
mine it has the only project in North
America that's permitted and in
construction its mine ther pass has been
in the works for 16 years and still has
another estimated 3 years of
construction to go it's an essential
metal for a lot of the technologies that
we need for the uh decarbonization of
the world every country wants to get
hold of lithium so that they can build
those
Technologies